der riesen brocken florence rast auf die
erde zu am ersten september 2017 wird er
der erde wohl so nahe kommen wie kein so
großer asteroiden zuvor gefährlich macht
ihn zum einen seine kreuzung zur
erdbeeren und zum anderen seine größe er
gehört zu den größten erdnahen
asteroiden überhaupt astronomie teams
weltweit sind vorgewarnt und schon im
nächsten monat soll ein weiterer street
der erde gefährlich nahe kommen
inzwischen kennt man die entfernung
besser in der sich der erde nähern wird
wie groß die gefahr diesmal wirklich ist
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
schon seit 36 jahren nahmen
forschungsteams weltweit den wirklich
riesigen hast du diesen florence im
blick 1981 hatte ihn ein us astronom
entdeckte am freitag den ersten
september ist es dann soweit er wird so
nah dran an der erde erwartet wie kein
so großer asteroid zuvor astronomie
teams weltweit sind deshalb vorgewarnt
und erwarten den tag mit großer spannung
währungskurse von 4,35 kilometern das
ist wirklich immens und seine kreuzung
zu erdbeeren machen ihn so gefährlich
seitdem vor etwa einem jahrhundert der
erste ärger hast du überhaupt entdeckt
wurde ist florence tatsächlich der
größte us solid der so nah an uns vorbei
fliegt mit einem abstand von 7.000
millionen kilometern so 7 milliarden
kilometer nämlich und in astronomischen
maßen see ist das tatsächlich wenig
allerdings nasa teams zufolge ist dies
immer noch weit genug entfernt um eine
gefahr für die erde auszuschließen und
trotzdem haben sie sich den tag rot im
kalender markiert die nasa plant rava
messung zum beispiel von kalifornien und
puerto rico aus und auch viele teleskope
werden den vorbeiflug von florence
beobachten und sicher nicht umsonst denn
der asteroid wird wohl heller am himmel
strahlen als beispielsweise 2014 nur 25
der mit einer distanz von 1,8 millionen
kilometern an der erde vorbei gerauscht
ist klar denn er war auch nur 650 meter
groß wenn das wetter mitspielt könnte
sogar möglich sein florence mit einem
guten fernglas zu entdecken und im
oktober geht es tatsächlich weiter mit
einem asteroiden in unserer nähe am 12
oktober wird wohl ein weiterer asteroid
die erde nur knapp verfehlen
und das ist wirklich knapp diesmal das
sind die neuen zahlen wohl nur mit einem
abstand von 44.000 kilometern ganz schön
nahe wenn man bedenkt dass die
geostationären satelliten in einer
entfernung von 36 kilometern von uns
entfernten konkret handelt es sich um
den asteroiden 2012 tc 4
nach berechnungen der forschungsteams
von esa und nasa besteht auch hier keine
anschlagsgefahr dieser suite ist in etwa
15 bis 20 meter lang und wurde 2012
entdeckt damals konnte er aufgrund
seines vorlaufes allerdings nur wenige
tage proben
werden seine größe endet übrigens dem
asteroiden der im februar 2013 über
russland explodiert ist allerdings erst
noch mal zehn mal größer also vom
volumen her die explosion des
chelyabinsk asteroiden hatte damals
lediglich eine druckwelle ausgelöst sie
beschädigte mehrere tausend gebäude und
verletzte rund 100 menschen ein
einschlag dagegen hätte die stadt
komplett zerstört verglichen mit der
hiroshima bombe hatte diese ass et die
20 bis 40 fache sprengkraft entsprechend
tnt waren es 600 kilotonnen asteroiden
sind ja ein überbleibsel von der
entstehung unseres sonnensystems die
meisten von ihnen ziehen
glücklicherweise weit entfernt von der
erde ihre runden um die sonne zwischen
den planeten mars und jupiter und doch
die erde ist ständig bedroht von
kollisionen mit erdnahen asteroiden
viele objekte sind klein und verglühen
in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es
bemerken dass ein himmelskörper in die
atmosphäre eindringt und explodiert oder
ein schräg das kommt allerdings öfter
vor als wir denken
wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren
passiert ist das wurde ja erst jüngst
bekannt wir haben darüber berichtet 26
asteoriden sind auf der erde in 13
jahren eingeschlagen darauf gekommen
sind findige wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen sie hatten die idee
beim weltweiten atomteststopp
überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es
andere größere explosionen auf der erde
gab und es waren 26 in 13 jahren
lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei
vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem
himmel jedes jahr schlagen also zwei
größere asteroiden hier auf der erde ein
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn die
gesteinsbrocken schlugen im meer wüsten
oder sonstigen unbewohnten gebieten ein
und verdampften bereits in der
atmosphäre jetzt will die nasa bei 2012
tc 4
die abwehr von erster jeden testen
erster schritt die nachverfolgung des us
zu ihnen 2012 tc 4 kennen wir zwar schon
seit fünf jahren aber in dieser zeit
konnten wir ihn nur sieben tage
beobachten der vorbeiflug soll jetzt
genutzt werden um die asteroiden
erkennung und nachverfolgung zu testen
denn das ist die voraussetzung um in
zukunft asteroiden aufzuspüren und dann
zu zerstören oder ihre flugbahn zu
ändern zum ersten mal kommt die neue
behörde planetary die fans koordination
also planeten verteidigungsreaktion zum
einsatz
diese hatten die usa letztes jahr
eingerichtet um erdnahe asteroiden zu
entdecken und zu verfolgen sie gelten
als auslöser von massensterben auf der
erde alle paar millionen jahre mal
steuert ein großer asteroid auf die erde
zu der das leben tatsächlich bedroht die
nase hat deswegen das ziel bis 2020 alle
erdnahen asteroiden
die zumindest größer als 140 meter sind
zu entdecken denn genau diese sind die
größte gefahr für die erde experten
plädieren deshalb immer wieder für eine
bessere weltweite zusammenarbeit und den
aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystems wirklich effektive
abwehr strategie n a
die gibt's noch gar nicht die sind noch
nicht ausgetüftelt wir können also froh
sein dass die beiden jetzt erwarteten
hast du jeden wohl wirklich keine gefahr
für das leben auf der erde darstellen
allerdings müssen wir fürchten dass
einer der statistisch gesehen zwei
asteroiden die das ja hier einschlagen
in einer gegend auf trifft in der
millionen menschen leben diese beiden
asteroiden werden es nicht sein aber
vielleicht einer den wir noch nicht
entdeckt haben hier bei pixum sind also
jeden eines unserer top themen wenn ihr
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
also hier geht es weiter mit astro ihn
bedrohen die erde jederzeit mit noch
mehr infos zu den gefahren die von
asteroiden ausgehen spannendes video
klar
also nicht verpassen und draufklicken
viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt